all right welcome back everybody okay so
today we're going to continue analyzing
the heat equation and we're going to do
a couple of things so we're going to
look at the heat equation when you have
nonlinear radiation away from the body
we're also going to look at how to write
the heat equation in 2d or 3d or n D and
then we're going to start to think about
how we would solve Laplace's equation
for the equilibrium temperature
distribution for 2d problems okay so
we're going to introduce one of the most
important techniques in this class
called the method of separation of
variables and how many of you have heard
of separation of variables before how
many have not heard of this okay good so
we're going to kind of motivate
separation of variables and separation
of variables is going to essentially set
the stage for why we want Fourier
transforms in the first place okay so
we're going to basically derive Fourier
transforms using this Laplace equation
in 2d okay so just a recap so we have
our heat equation in 1d and our heat
equation in 1d was pretty
straightforward if we assume that we're
dealing with you know one material like
a metal or plastic or something that has
the same thermal properties throughout
then we can write this as a linear
partial differential equation so we have
the time derivative of our temperature
field U is equal to some constant you
know you could actually write it all out
as K over CP or C Rho times the second
partial derivative in X okay so this is
a diffusion term and what that means
physically is that if I have some
localized variations in temperature over
time they're going to diffuse and spread
out so that gradients and temperature
kind of averaged out
some common temperature now we had a
number of assumptions that went into
writing this equation down so one of the
assumptions was that all of our thermal
properties along this 1d span or rod
were constant so KC and Rho are all
constants specific heat density and
thermal diffusion coefficient we also
made the assumption that this thing was
insulated with some kind of an
insulating jacket so that there was
insulation here and we also assumed that
there were no thermal sources or sinks q
so we also assumed that this Q term is
equal to zero okay so it turns out that
if this rod is not insulated you get
some pretty interesting properties to
this partial differential equation okay
so what would you assume would happen if
I did not have insulation across this
rod so maybe I had some some ambient
temperature so we're going to call this
ambient temperature u naught and now
let's say that our bar is able to
radiate heat out from the entire span so
how would my equation change in this
case yeah he lost or imputed convection
yeah so I have a heat loss term due to
convection and/or radiation what would
that heat loss term look like let's say
that the difference in temperature
between the bar and the ambient is
relatively small like maybe the
difference in temperature between my
hand and the air
oh yeah so you might have something like
the Delta temperature which is my
temperature you - you not so I would
probably have some term that looked like
you know minus a constant times my
temperature at all points X and T minus
my ambient temperature okay and this
constant would tell me basically how
fast heat is being transferred from the
bar to the surroundings so if I'm a bar
in air this mu would be smaller than if
I'm a bar in water and if I was a bar in
air with a breeze then this mu would be
larger than if I was a bar in still air
right because he would be carried away
faster and this is something that you
want to determine probably empirically
but there are theories for how to
determine this okay but what if I have
really really large temperature
temperature differences or what if
there's actually no ambient fluid
surrounding this at all what if this
thing is just an outer space okay so
this body also radiates heat and how
does heat radiates from a body sorry
yeah so it's like some other constants
I'll just keep calling it mu times Delta
temperature to the fourth power okay so
this is the so called blackbody
radiation discovered by Boltzmann and
this is clearly a nonlinear term in our
PD right if I have a large temperature U
or at least a large temperature with
respect to the ambient then this term is
quadratic
sorry not quadratic it's quartic in the
non-linearity and this actually becomes
a really nasty nonlinear heat problem so
I still have a diffusion term but now I
have this nonlinear radiation term this
is basically the reason that the earth's
temperature doesn't keep raising and
raising and raising because we're
getting a solar
load from the Sun because as our
temperature rises the amount of
radiation that comes out of the earth
through blackbody radiation
eventually balances the amount of
thermal energy that we're getting in
from the Sun so for us we actually have
a plus Q from the Sun but we have this
black body radiation term that
essentially balances the energy we're
getting from the Sun and since we have
an atmosphere things are a little bit
more complicated and our temperature is
higher than the predicted blackbody
radiation because we trap some of this
radiating heat and it reflects back and
forth okay so this is just kind of I
want to give you an idea that the simple
linear PDE that we're going to write
down in all of the examples that follow
is just an approximation it's a very
good approximation for most things it's
a good approximation for how heat
transfers out of my cup or how you know
things bake in an oven but you need
additional terms if you want to describe
the full physics and sometimes these
terms are nonlinear okay so today I want
to talk to you about the 2d and 3d heat
equation and this is going to bring back
some of the ideas that we had from
vector calculus so we're going to be
using Gauss's divergence theorem we're
going to be using control volumes and
we're going to be essentially writing
down conservation laws in some kind of a
fixed volume okay so in 2d and 3d we
have the same basic physics okay so heat
equation in 2d and 3d and really this
doesn't matter if I'm in 2 or 3d the
math is going to be true for n D okay so
the basic physics is the same as last
time right the time rate of change of
heat energy in a volume is equal to the
heat energy flux out of the volume plus
any sort
terms or sync terms okay so first I'm
just going to draw this volume this is a
little different than what we did last
time because now we're actually going to
write this conservation of heat energy
over some kind of a control volume my
surface I'm going to call it s I might
have some normal vector and vector and
I'm still going to use these vector
symbols to denote vector and I could
choose this control volume in lots of
different ways I could have it so that
my object that I'm studying is
completely inside of here like my coffee
cup right my coffee cup can be
completely inside the control volume or
I could have a control volume where I'm
analyzing some little piece of my coffee
cup okay I could have my control volume
over some little section of my coffee
cup that's totally fine the basic math
and what we're going to write down is
the same for any volume you can write
down okay so we have rate of change of
heat energy this is exactly the same as
last time heat energy in time is equal
to the heat energy flux through the
boundaries through boundaries plus heat
energy generated over the volume
and both of these are you know in the
volume through sorry through boundary of
the volume okay so this basically makes
sense right this is just you know you
can't this is conservation of energy
okay this is the thermodynamic
equivalent of conservation of energy if
I have some integrated amount of thermal
heat energy inside this volume there's
only two ways it can possibly change
right I can bleed energy out or gain
energy you know coming in through the
boundaries or I can have some source of
energy in here I can have some chemical
reaction I can have some you know
nuclear material that's splitting and
radiating energy but those are the only
ways that I can change the amount of
heat energy in my volume in time right
basic physics we've known this for a
long time and I'm just saying it in
words but now we're doing this over a
control volume so the way that we write
this down in math is a little bit
different than we did in 1d we're going
to write this in terms of surface and
volume integrals okay so what's my rate
of change of heat energy in time first
of all what's my total heat energy in
this volume
okay so I got some integral over a
control line integral of Rho V these
triple integrals eventually I'm going to
stop writing triple integrals because I
hate triple integrals it's is really
just an integral over the volume you can
choose any way of doing it you like okay
so I have an integral over the volume of
what times what times what
well I'm integrating my specific heat
times my density times my velocity field
not my velocity field my temperature
field okay so this is my total heat
energy in the volume and I'm looking at
the time rate of change the only way
that this energy can change in time is
for these two things to happen so notice
here that I've written you as just a
regular number but X as a vector
okay that's because this is a scalar
temperature field so for every point in
space for every vector X in space I have
one number which tells me the
temperature at that point so U is a
scalar but X is a vector okay so this is
a scalar field that's what we call this
okay now how do I write a flux integral
through my volume what does that look
like
okay the integral over my surface also
going to stop writing this funny double
weird integral it's just an integral
over the surface sometimes we'll say
that this is partial V in like advanced
math this is usually how we denote the
boundary of B okay and what is the flux
energy through this volume so remember Q
was this vector is grad U and this is my
heat flux okay so I'm going to take that
Q dotted into my normal Direction D s
right so anytime I have some heat flux Q
I want to know how much of that heat
flux is in the normal direction meaning
how much of that
you flex can escape this this volume and
how much heat flux is actually being
recirculated back into the volume okay
so I just want the component that's
normal and I'm going to integrate up all
of those normal components over the
entire surface and that tells me how
much heat is bleeding out or being fed
in and then I have this last term which
is pretty simple just volume integral of
Q of X DB if I have any sources they get
just added up in a volume okay any
questions about how we wrote this what
these terms mean what the physics means
like I want this to be this should feel
pretty comfortable at this point the
basic idea of conservation of heat
energy in words and then writing those
down in integrals like this should be
kind of our foundation for for P DS at
this point okay so in lecture 23 of the
last quarter we did this exact same
process for the conservation of mass for
mass continuity and we derived the
continuity equation and fluids very very
similar idea except it was the time rate
of change of mass and my volume equal
the amount of mass flux out of the
boundary of my volume plus any mass
sources in my volume any divergence you
know where mass is being created and we
wrote down a partial differential
equation so I would recommend that you
look over that and kind of reefa Miller
eyes yourself but what's the next step
in this in this equation like what's the
what's the most obvious the next thing I
should do here or try to do or maybe
asked another way why am i writing this
in terms of some arbitrary control
volume that I just made up in the first
place sorry it's a closed surface so I
can do my accounting and I don't lose
track of anything so I can do accounting
on the surface that's right another
reason is because the thing I just wrote
down is true for this control volume and
this control volume and this one and any
control volume that I can name this is
just a property of physics it's always
true and so I could shrink this control
volume to some tiny little piece of this
domain and it has to be true there and
next to it and next to it and all over
this domain and so if I can write this
as some volume integral of some equation
equals zero then I get this differential
equation has to equal zero okay so let's
see if we can turn this flux integral
into a volume integral okay whenever you
think of a flux integral what are you
like what's the theorem from vector
calculus that we should be using okay
Gauss's theorem what does Gauss's
theorem tell me about this flux integral
ok surface integral of Q dotted in the
normal Direction equals a volume
integral of what this equals minus a
volume integral of what it's not just
Gauss's theorem it's Gauss's divergence
theorem so we need to take the
divergence of Q okay and now this thing
is a scalar div dot my vector field Q is
a scalar and I integrate that scalar
field over my volume
okay and so we can finally write this
equation as one big volume integral okay
so this term is going to basically stay
the same I'm going to say triple volume
integral of C Rho partial u partial T DV
and I'm bringing the DDT in I'm assuming
that my specific heat and density don't
change in time so U is the only thing
that can change in time that's going to
equal minus my volume integral of div
dot Q okay plus my volume integral of my
source terms good so now these are all
kind of apples and apples comparison
we're doing volume integrals over the
same volume V there's no surface
integrals and so I can bring all of
these quantities inside under the volume
integral so I have volume integral of C
Rho partial u partial T plus the
divergence of Q the flux minus big Q and
this whole volume integral equals zero
okay now the really cool thing is that
this is true for all V for all volumes
this is true for all volumes this is
even true if weird stuff is happening
inside of this volume I'll talk about
that in a little bit this is even true
if these derivatives don't really exist
or the system is discontinuous this is
true for all volumes and what that means
is that this thing on the inside the
integrand always has to equal zero
that's the only possible way that this
integral could be equal to zero for
volumes so this is only true this is if
and only if cero partial u partial T
equals minus grad sorry divergence of Q
plus big Q okay so this is my my
differential equation this has to be
true because this integral is equal to 0
for all volumes I can name conservation
of thermal energy the first law of
thermodynamics is always true it's true
inside this pen and in a circle
surrounding this pen inside my coffee
cup inside this room if I drew a big
sphere around the whole earth that
conservation law would be true so since
this is true on all volumes this
differential equation is true at all
points X and at all times T for all X
and T ok we're almost done
the last thing that I need to do is to
get rid of this divergence of Q I want
this entire thing to be in terms of use
right my temperature fields so what did
i do before what is Q equal all right Q
is grad U is Q gradual or is it minus
grad u you think it's minus grad u yeah
let's say that this is minus let's say
that Q is minus K grad u that's maybe a
little more precise so K Q is minus K
grad U and we're taking minus divergence
of Q so let's write this down so we have
minus divergence of Q ok I'm going to
get rid of the minus minus K I'm just
going to say that this is K times the
divergence of the gradient of U
right okay and we can actually write
this out long ways because I want to
convince you that this is not too
complicated so this is K times okay I
can write this divergence operator as a
vector you know
Dell dot is a vector partial partial X
partial partial Y partial partial Z it's
a vector it multiplies other vectors and
I'm taking the dot of that with this
gradient vector which is partial u
partial X partial u partial Y and
partial u partial Z and so if I just dot
these two vectors I get you know second
derivative of U with respect to X plus
second derivative of U with respect to Y
plus second derivative of U with respect
to Z so that's K times u xx plus uy y
plus u ZZ and that's equal to this
laplacian operator on you this is just K
times the laplacian of u okay so
divergence of gradient of a scalar field
is equal to the laplacian of that scalar
field we just wrote it out long ways and
that's true and so I can further
simplify this expression so I can say
partial u partial t is equal to K over C
Rho times the laplacian of u let's say
that there's no Q terms this is if Q
equals zero okay so this is my 2d 3d nd
heat equation okay that's it this is how
you derive this heat equation we're
going to spend the next two
sure's maybe three lectures finding new
and interesting ways of solving this
we're going to plot the solutions in
MATLAB and really understand like so we
know that we've coded up the physics
into this partial differential equation
and we're going to start interpreting
solutions of this partial differential
equation to understand physically what
happens you know how heat transfers
through materials through solids and
volumes and shapes okay any questions
about this big picture derivation of the
2d and 3d heat equation yeah this does
not take into account radiator terms
yeah it doesn't take into account
radiator terms I mean oftentimes we are
this is basically just assuming that we
have some kind of an insulated material
if you did have radiative terms then you
would use the solution of this as an
initial guess for a simulation of the
full nonlinear PD because we don't have
analytic tools to solve this term with
nonlinear radiative terms so we'd
essentially have to like write a
simulation but we still learn a
tremendous amount about what happens in
that heat system just from this linear
equation with no radiation and we'll
talk a lot about that in this course
there's a general theme in partial
differential equations where if I have
so this is a really good question you're
bringing up I could have a partial
differential equation UT plus let's see
how do I want to do this u dot grad u
plus laplacian of u maybe this is like u
squared equals zero okay so let's say
that I have a partial differential
equation with two terms in addition to
my DDT so I have this nonlinear term
and I had this diffusion term often what
we'll do is we'll split this problem up
into two parts we'll look at just this
equation and we'll see what is the
solution of that and then we'll look at
just the diffusion equation this is
minus plus and will essentially analyze
the solutions of these separately and
then we'll try to make physical
arguments about what would happen if we
brought those two terms together maybe
they work together maybe they compete
against each other but that's a general
strategy in PDEs in general in fluid
dynamics we do that we split our
convection terms and our diffusion terms
and we handle them separately in
simulations you do that I might first
solve this step and then solve this step
and then iterate them this is a long way
of telling you that even though we're
neglecting additional nonlinear terms
now it's still very important to be able
to analyze this linear heat equation
okay okay good any other questions at
all about the derivation this make
pretty good sense or there are lots of
questions pretty good sense okay if this
doesn't if you're not comfortable with
this idea of taking some fundamental
conservation law conservation of mass
energy or momentum and writing it down
as a you know integral and then using
various theorems in vector calculus to
get a common integral to finally get a
differential equation there's lots of
examples to go through this so for
example continuity of mass you can
Google you know derivation of the Navy
or Stokes equation and you'll find
conservation of momentum this is
conservation of thermal energy there's
more of these one question that I was
maybe expecting is why do we want an
equation in this for
in the first place why is this somehow
better than this does anyone have any
idea is why we would want this
differential equation instead of a like
a volume integral
Sorry Sorry I can break up my domain
into a bunch of little pieces in time
and in space we know how to do finite
difference derivatives we know how to do
finite difference you know gradients and
things like that so I could possibly
code this up easier any other good
reasons why we might want to do this
yeah I might be able to do something
like separation of variables where I
assume a form of the solution and I plug
it into this equation and I might be
able to turn this into a bunch of
ordinary differential equations which
you couldn't necessarily do up here so
those are both great reasons it turns
out that this is kind of a that's not a
dirty secret but this equation here this
volume expression is actually called the
strong form of our PDE and this is the
weak form now it turns out that this is
actually more true more often and this
is a more general and powerful
expression because maybe I actually
don't have a continuous heat
distribution maybe I have
discontinuities and maybe I can't
compute the DDX or the DDT because they
are infinity okay so as a simple example
I could have a you know I could have a
hot slab of material and I could have a
cold slab of material and I could
instantaneously but them up against each
other and at least for a very very small
amount of time I have a step function in
the temperature right it steps down from
left to right and I don't have a DDX
right I can't compute the laplacian of
that temperature distribution because I
have an infinite derivative at that
interface for a very short amount of
time
this volume expression 10
to still be true the heat energy flux
the surface integral the rate of change
in time and the heat sources are
basically always true this is true even
if my system is discontinuous okay and
there are lots of simulations and
computational strategies that are
actually based on this volume integral
so they try to make this equal to zero
exactly and those tend to be pretty good
numerical strategies okay
that's something we'll get into a little
bit later but I don't want you to think
that the partial differential equation
is the you know end-all be-all of
writing down physics because the
integral formulation is also very very
important
so so I'm trying to decide how fast to
go through this and I feel like I should
give a little bit of just a little bit
more detail about how these would be
written in coordinates in 2d and 3d so
this is probably familiar to most of you
but it's still important
so we have our partial u partial T
equals some positive constant times the
laplacian of u ok and I'm just calling
this alpha square because I want this
number to be positive so I'm just going
to write down what this would look like
in 2d so in 2d we have u partial T
equals alpha squared times what is my
laplacian and 2d look like
ux x plus uy y and everyone is okay with
me using subscripts for partials yep
okay
in 3d pretty similar alpha squared u x x
plus uy y plus uz z okay what about nd
how do I write this now this is a little
bit more complicated UT equals alpha
squared times something is that
something X 1 1 X 2 2 X 3 3 X 4 4 dot
yeah that's right so I'm going to index
my spatial variable X 1 X 2 X 3 X 4 X 5
etc and so I get the sum from k equals 1
to n of partial squared u partial XK
squared okay that's how we write it down
in coordinates
this is how we write it down in vector
form this is how we write it down in
coordinates and you is just a scalar so
you is just one number at all points in
space and time okay good now the same
thing applies if we have equilibrium
then this satisfies Laplace's equation
and so in 2d we have you know laplacian
of u equals zero just means that ux x
plus uy y equals zero and it's basically
the same in 3d 4d 5d ND okay good so now
what I want to do is we're going to
start trying to actually solve a
relatively difficult problem and this is
going to motivate a lot of the tools
that we're going to use for even more
advanced problems so we're going to
solve a 2d equilibrium heat distribution
problem so we're going to we're going to
solve laplace in 2d for the equilibrium
temperature distribution now this is
probably going to take this will
definitely take the rest of this lecture
it'll probably take most of next lecture
okay because we're going to actually
solve this pretty difficult problem as
general as we can make it we're going to
motivate Fourier transforms and Fourier
integrals they're going to come out of
seemingly nowhere we're also going to
look at why it's so important that our
PDEs are linear so we're going to use
linear superposition and we're also
going to start coding this up in MATLAB
to see that we really can actually use
these solutions to visualize our key
distributions to understand the
okay so the simple simple system that
we're going to solve is the following so
I have a rectangle of some material I'm
going to solve the Laplace equation
inside this rectangle okay so I have
essentially a heat equation I'm going to
take time going to infinity I'm going to
find the equilibrium heat distribution
and I'm going to find this heat
distribution let's say that this thing
is you know 0 by length L and the height
is y equals 0 to height H okay with L
height H and so we're going to solve
this thing with four boundary conditions
we need a boundary condition on the
bottom so U of X at height zero is equal
to f1 of X we're going to start you know
trying out different functions and see
what these look like our second boundary
condition is U of all points X at a
height H equals some second function U
at x equals 0 and y equals some third
function of Y and I need a fourth
boundary condition on this side U of L
comma y equals F 4 of Y ok now this
doesn't this actually isn't that that
difficult right imagine that this is a
steel plate it's insulated on either
side ok so maybe it has some kind of a
you know heat shield on either side of
this and I have you know a blowtorch on
the left side keeping its temperature at
one distribution I have you know a bath
of water on the right side keeping its
temperature cold on that side and I have
something on the top and the bottom
right I'm just fixing the boundary
condition temperatures and I want to
know what is the heat profile at all
points in the middle here what's the
equilibrium heat distribution
does the basic setup make sense okay
we'll also be able to generalize this to
things like circular disk or triangle I
mean you'll be able to solve all kinds
of interesting problems using this and
this is really a stepping stone to much
more complicated problems so we also are
going to use this solution that we're
going to develop this lecture and next
to figure out what happens in transients
if I also had if I also have this
transient UT term partial u partial T if
I had the full heat equation and I
wanted to know what how this evolved in
time towards the equilibrium we'll also
be able to solve that once we know how
to solve this okay good I have ten
minutes left so I'm going to tell you
the strategy of how we're going to solve
this and then on Wednesday we're going
to go through kind of the details and
actually figure out how to do this okay
any questions about the problem set up
the boundary conditions the motivation
any of that I mean this is actually
getting to be a problem that might be
interesting to solve this is not a toy
problem anymore you might actually want
to know the temperature distribution on
some surface okay so because our partial
differential equation laplacian squared
of U equals zero is linear there's a
really really cool trick I can do where
I can solve this partial differential
equation using simpler boundary
conditions and I can add up those
solutions in linear superposition so
because this is linear we can solve for
simpler boundary condition problems
and add up the solutions okay so what
does that look like so I have my
solution
you know f1 f2 f3 f4 and my solution is
U of X and T and this is going to equal
if I took this rectangle and I just had
f1 on the bottom but I made zero
temperatures everywhere else this is a
simpler problem right look simpler I
have less constraints or at least more
simple constraints they're zeros here
let's call this u 1 and I could add to
that this system where I have a
temperature fixed on the top and zeros
everywhere else
let's call that solution u 2 plus f3000
u 3 plus f 4 0 0 0 u 4 ok this is pretty
huge the fact that our PDE is linear
means that if I take u 1 which is a
solution of this and u 2 which is a
solution of this u 3 of this C 4 of this
and I add them all up they the sum will
satisfy all of these boundary conditions
because like let's think about this so
u2 u3 and u4 all satisfied the bottom
boundary condition equaling 0 so if I
add those two u 1 then my bottom
boundary condition equals f1 right that
solution those solutions all add and so
the bottom solution of u1 plus u2 plus
u3 + u 4 is f1 similarly the top
boundary condition if I add up all of
these is f2 the left boundary condition
if I add all of them up is f3 and the
right
new condition is f4 so the some of those
four separate simpler problems all
satisfy this complicated boundary
condition okay I want you to think about
this this is really important so I want
you to like I'll probably try to say
this again on Wednesday but between now
and then I want you to be thinking about
why is it true that I can solve this
problem on these four simpler boundary
conditions and when I add up all of
those solutions I satisfy all of my
boundary conditions from before this is
extremely important this is the basic
idea of linearity is that linearity
allows me to decompose my problem into
simpler subplots solve each of them and
then add them up okay so I'm going to
show you how to solve one of these
problems we're going to solve this one
okay so let's solve for you three of x
and y and the same basic strategy that
we use to solve this system we're going
to be able to solve u 1 u 2 and u 4 and
then we can add those up and get the
solution to our original equation this
is super important if you do one thing
between now and Wednesdays lecture I
want you to think about this and really
convince yourself that this is true like
this is one of the foundational
principles of partial differential
equations that you can break down your
problem into pieces and sum up the
solutions if your PDE is linear okay one
way you could convince yourself is you
could actually take you on u2 u3 and u4
add them up and plug them into this
equation and you'll find that this is
still true so the sum does satisfy the
equation as long as each of these
satisfies the equation and then you
could go through each boundary condition
and verify that the boundary condition
really is satisfied with the sum of the
Solutions okay so we're going to solve
this simpler problem where now what we
have here is we're just solving for this
third temperature field u3 with much
simpler boundary conditions okay we have
a left boundary condition and then the
bottom right and top are all equal to
zero okay questions about the big
picture of how we're going to solve this
I kind of feel like it would be a
mistake to die of any deeper in the next
five minutes
because the next thing is probably the
most important I'm going to essentially
we're going to write down what
separation of variable means and we're
going to write down this equation using
that separation of variables I'm just
going to write it down so we will assume
that u 3 of x and y equals just some
function of x times just some other
function of Y and then using our four
boundary conditions you know 1 2 3 & 4
and our partial differential equation
we're going to back out things that have
to be true of F and G we're going to
solve for what F must hat must be and
what G must be using this boundary
conditions and partial differential
equation okay that's all for today
Wednesday we're actually going to solve
this problem that we wrote out right
here and then we're going to start
visualizing it in matlab and it's going
to motivate Fourier transforms okay
thank you
you